this is long live the earth Queen last
time on Korra Doug Walker claimed that
avatar wasn't taking any risks now what
do you have to say for yourself I say
the elf queen has failed to have kingdom
all rise up and come up with a better
plan that I have oh my how the tables
have turned
it's hot long enough but it's yeah Wow
Hey Oh No oh yeah love is ill oh well
okay both fair on if it took long enough
oh my god it's like okay good cause
building to something yeah but no we
could have had this like two three
episodes ago I mean but it's if he says
not knowing how the next couple of
episodes are okay
it's like it I'm glad we finally have
like something major going on you know
oh you know what you always wouldn't
jack
even this episode honestly if you
chopped off that ending this would have
been like all the other so it's really
but all of it get laws now they have to
put this shit back together and older
I'm sorry I feel good they gave us
frickin shy the lewd from dune out of
the den they got a desert shirt a santur
a fucking Land Shark they gave us a
giant Land Shark annual yeah whatever I
got away
it's not until the ending where it's
just like Olli shit I gave this bottle
what you were watching but they had me
at Land Shark
so for it's a recap here um pretty much
a mock oh and uh Bolan their capture
they're being taken to the earth Queen
and Korra and I forget her name
Asami penis hair yeah uh they're
captured - Pacific yeah she's from she's
from oh yeah no I know that I've with
the damn good well my sporting of you
but for some reason I was thinking like
in animated form I'm like when did she
have in Korra no no this is going really
Brown go put this on automatic exposure
cuz what yeah
right now yeah that's always it's always
the one downside of doing it where we
are is that like I like how he's doing
this line is it's gonna be edited out of
the final product no no it'll be in
there so okay but I think that made it
worse oh well hopefully the automatic
exposure won't catch on but uh we'll
just be glowing Lewis will just be
glowing like we're on Krypton yeah okay
I'm gonna put the exposure to access
just got charming nuts
so sorry so long to the making of like
the behind the scene is always a really
really boring it's a lot of just doing
that pushing buttons on your camera now
watching that now the like the whites go
there go there go so screw it this is
the setting we'll do it live so um yeah
so uh Cora and penis hair they escape
and they find a way to get along with
you know kinda their captors the earth
Queens people and they're like okay like
we cool we cool you know you guys go do
whatever and they meet up with Zuko he's
back in and the dragon I gave you Zuko
and the dragon again at the end yes but
we had a wait a while for a natus but
it's I think he's better it's great it's
all coming together it's all part of the
plan I love the image of the dragon with
Thea wasn't the tube camels or horses or
whatever they're just like this look at
the dragon um and yeah the biggie that
we got is that the villains go to the
earth Queen and pretty much just like
cure a pretty savage way enough are out
like the obnoxious little flame that she
is it's what we aim at it's one of those
things where I'm watching else like yeah
I can't believe no other Airbender every
thought that's like I guess this is why
they're so peaceful and all about the
balance and everything cuz yeah that's
like doc Airbender he's a Sith Airbender
yeah that's like the that's like blood
bending it's like blood bending plus
like it just out of why that never
occurred to me but it's like yeah you
just saw the oxygen that it's it's such
a creepy idea to see it kind of app and
it's like ooh like you know we don't
like the earth Queen cuz she's a villain
but she's kind of comical I don't know
what's stopping her though from the
second she passes out taking another
breath him cuz you've sucked the oxygen
out you can still breathe back in once
it sucked out cuz I saw the air clearly
go away but you know love sure he could
we cheer fall over but I don't think we
saw him stop or whatever he could just
kept Xing it out oh no we didn't see the
scene where she's still breathing and he
decides to feed her to the bear no the
bears Cubs the kids it's their revenge
ah the bear wait wait they're not duck
bear caller oh no it just just jamberry
we're just a bit um so yeah things are
finally they're going now and we got
this big rebellion going on it is kind
of you know Dark Knight Rises I guess uh
and we'll see where that goes but yeah
now it's like do like what what's gonna
happen I'm like where's before it's like
I liked it it was good but there's never
this Oh can't wait for the next episode
now it's like a really really hype for
this now are you happy yes yes I am with
like there's a few episodes earlier but
you know it's it out happy when when
well it'll be interesting to see what
they do with it - because they said they
don't have that many left I mean they
only have a couple left so I'm curious
to see what this all kind of builds -
and it's we haven't really seen
something quite like that yet I hear a
spit and the earth Kingdom is the
perfect place to do it because there was
so much repression you know not not just
uh you know this generation but
generations before so this seems like oh
it's going to go down like Iraq yeah
like this is the perfect place to mu-1
oh I have this theory that it's like
just gonna be total chaos because you've
had this repressive regime and now it's
just like well nobody's running the show
so it's like a free-for-all and then I
will kill them all how does that make me
say it
just does long hauls al Ghul and I beat
my men will be right in my own answer
I'm sorry peanut film way too long it's
a time to get past time to move on but I
had to edit in the top eleven trailers
it was so stupid
okay so some more recent things Man of
Steel Man of Steel there we go
Connect that to core that's like or to
that will never look I'll never let go
Dark Knight Rises you'll never let go of
Man of Steel and we'll just want to see
the fan bicker and fight whatever we
mention it but dads puppets dance up
anywho oh it's so enough this was uh I
mean it's a good episode it's again it
was kind of the same balance of the
other episodes until it got to that
ending where it's only just took a big
leap into holy shit territory I'm
waiting for the moment when Bolin can
finally metalbend that was a pretty good
fake out I thought okay at this time
he's definitely gonna do it like he's
got this now galatea doors open yet I'm
like oh good okay now cuz I thought they
were gonna do it I love that lines like
Bolin stop trying to make friends with
the bad guy yeah I'll get some some good
laps in it um and let's be honest the
earth Queen had it coming
no she it's like yeah but they still
made her kind of you know even though
she was mean and evil she was kind of
goofy as well and so I really would not
have guessed they would have killed her
off I think they would have I thought
they would have made it even if you were
to kill off my on the character outside
of you know the for bending villains it
it's her who else were you know no it's
a fact that if they were gonna kill
again for primarily a show on
Nickelodeon I basically pitch babes
would appear it yeah I I don't think
they would have done um they would have
made her comical you know uh but which
in a comical in the same raizy
yes way yeah like it's it was more of
like and I done say this is like yeah it
was comical but also like a comma in a
comically way I'm like I want to see her
dead yeah I just hated her so much I'm
not gonna quote miss her you know
because it's like well okay she's like
this sort of character on a reality TV
show you can't wait to get voted off huh
but but I didn't think they would go
that route as that is why I got voted
off with her life
it's yeah it wasn't that's a pretty
disturbing deci like it's not it's like
amore the eyes were bulging out like
something at a Total Recall it well and
usually the way they get away with that
stuff in in kid shows is that they can
do it but then like they don't really
die or they come back because that's
always the way out the parrot I don't
think she kind of guy but no it's like
they they weren't all the way it knows
it was I yeah I thought at first that it
was actually a fake out because it cut
away every thought it was - I then I was
just like oh my god I mean well I mean I
guess Tenneco as I mean technically they
could bring her back you know what
though if they do that I'm just saying
no balls I'm like now just make sure
she's gone I don't know I like I
couldn't see in the story or anything
how like in iron I'm just saying that I
don't know why they would I'm just
saying it's theoretically possible
because we don't see the body yeah but
so it's like they kind of shown enough
it's the next thing like dragged her
body put her head on a spike like Game
of Thrones no I'll be the next like
Avatar comic it'll be like you know you
had the search for Zuko's mother now
it's the search for the earth Queen it's
like where did she go it's such a
mystery as a part of her here a part of
it is not ever there um so yeah it's a
chorus still great um you know I line
when I love one but that stay in shark
whatever is about to eat them and
they're practically in there and she
gets them out there so few times we see
her get the people loud and I love
Asami's intricate knowledge of
engineering and her competitors to such
a way that she's like no Jamie to the
wall and then she's like no I know these
things are designed dirt cheap you get
what you pay for
it's like a message an ad and it's like
this is a cheap piece of crap you know
flying craft it's like watch this and
then I love it there's some line to
where she rips up something else he's
like man these things really are cheap
yeah so I thought that was a great scene
um I thought Bolin was funny um trying
what else that happened I just
everywhere it's just the ending the end
is
it's getting real yeah I can't wait to
see where they go from here uh so is she
like that's the question is like Korra
gonna restore order to the earth Kingdom
are they going to elect a new leader I
did sounded like there were riots in the
streets Oh mm so yeah well the villains
realize oh maybe like this wasn't a good
idea cuz now people are killing each
other or will they just be like well I
gotta break a few eggs to make an omelet
ya know that's kind of my thoughts they
just feel I know this is a cleansing
it's the power yeah I mean that it kind
of sounds like that's what they're we
try me cuz they kill thing the coop
going into is thinking like you know
whoa I didn't think this was gonna
happen I thought we're gonna be greeted
as liberators and you know cuz that
totally doesn't match reality at all um
yeah good an arrow but ya know I it's a
real good episode it's a good start to
where the hell is this gonna go and I I
really enjoyed it I I can't wait for the
next one yeah there's not much there's
really not much else to say just cuz
it's a giant question mark at the moment
and be like what do you have to say what
do you have to say I'm like well it's
awesome but par for that not much cuz
this part of the story just kind of
started I'm like I don't know where you
go from here I can't wait to find out
but ya know I'm like whereas before I
was liking it but I was like I was
missing that kind of passion what's
gonna happen the next one now it's like
I I'm really excited I play with you
like a harp from hell
like you said that literally the episode
before everything goes down yeah I mean
it's just it's I again I should enjoy to
talk you know right at the exact moment
that you're just like I'm wanting
something then they give it to you I I
was saying that several episodes back
though so are you showing SEPA so no I I
said I said is it getting a formula but
I was saying before I read a single live
in cameras let's turn on the computer
and watch all the past episodes no cuz I
don't like watching us particularly you
well I don't like watching you either
yeah really you went on Princess Diaries
- um yes which is amazing we
is it it's just not the most amazing
Disney sequel ever so I had a computer
virus on my machine so I didn't get to
watch core I just got my machine bag I
didn't get to watch it till pretty much
this morning it's Wednesday morning and
yeah so I watched it and then he came
over and we watched Princess Diaries 2
for the NC and there's a scene where I
swear to God Anne Hathaway steps on
Chris Pines toes and then storms off and
goes poof and like what do you say to
that like I'm like I don't think I've
seen a scene like that in a movie since
like a cartoon maybe could get away with
that but this is totally like this is
off topic and it's only on top and I'm
just saying I don't did you not have
like whoo so the comedy in Cora is bad
watch The Princess Diaries you do not
have is not the most entertaining ly bad
it's like 2 hours but it felt like just
an hour long it was amazing we had like
a line per minute it's amazing this is
gonna be like the most edited down
episode because there is so much there
is at any point in this movie where they
hit such a low such desperation that two
maids as a distraction singing frre
Jacques and put giant pots on their head
like literally dance around with giant
pots on their head take them off and
then clang them together
clang and then smile and I lost it for
10 minutes and I'm like I know why she
did again that I was the funniest thing
I've ever seen it's just so sad so
desperate it's it's one of the great
comedies for the exact opposite reasons
that intended um its if we can't make
white hilarious review out of that like
but to connect it to Cora if you can
Bolin is bad
watch Princess Diaries - you'll realize
that you know Belinda is what an ad for
the show if you felt the way was bad
watch princes diamonds I get my guy
Clint my insulting Cora Princess Diaries
- that I don't listen yeah it bottomed I
it's a good episode of you haven't seen
it go check it out and check out
Princess Diaries to either the movie or
our review
whatever it's it's amazing it's pretty
funny
Wow we told me derail this sorry this is
good